modern matriarchs so let's open this up
this is a
female-led relationship has become more
common than ever ever as women are
increasingly viewed as equal powerful
and able to take on a formerly masculine
what does that mean a formerly masculine
role
are they are they purporting that men
are like trying to abandon masculinity
or is it because you're trying to
squeeze it out of us by constantly
calling us toxically masculine and all
that nonsense anyway let's see what this
article says here this is from couples
candy the ultimate beginner's guide to
female-led relationships by author megan
harrison
this is a january this is a very recent
article so here's megan hi i'm megan and
welcome to couples candy here you'll
find lots of practical information
dedicated to enhancing your relationship
and boosting your well-being as a
marriage and family therapist i love
helping people reconnect with their
partners in order to experience greatest
satisfaction from their relationships
all right let's see what megan harrison
has to uh tell us about female-led
relationships so identifying importance
of boundaries of perks the drop all
right let's go to uh the different types
identifying importance of boundaries
female let's see what their boundaries
are communicate openly find a
comfortable balance discuss your
expectations
ah that's standard mumbo jumbo new wave
stuff discuss your expectation okay
types of female
level oh they have levels fellas
they have let here you know what
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna show off my
brand new desk
check this out
hey clickety click barbatric look at
that
stand up and do this do this show why
not
oh
there we go
let's give this a go stand up desks are
fun
level one lower female control
this flr level involves at least power
differential both parties make nearly
all decisions together that sounds like
an equal partnership
with the female taking control only in
specific previously agreed on situations
so
equal with her having slightly more
control
in some cases couples decide to initiate
a female-led relationship but
transitioning to a power role is
difficult for the women asserting
dominance may feel foreign or
uncomfortable that's because it is
that's because it always has been
for the most part throughout history
but
just ignore history who cares we'll just
you know
let's just throw it all on a women's
show they don't want to lead guys they
hate it they want you to they want to
look up to a giant they want to be with
a guy that's competent and knows what
he's doing
anyway it may take some time and
encouragement for a woman to move from
passive to a dominant role it's not
uncommon for couples to shift to a
higher level of female dominance once
the woman's comfort level increases all
right level two moderate let's see what
moderate looks like when the woman takes
on a more moderate level of control in
the relationship she's typically more
comfortable in her dominant role she is
generally the primary decision maker
that would suck men in this that's that
basically sounds like most men's
marriages today though right doesn't it
she ends up being the primary decision
maker
men in this dynamic tend to enjoy taking
on a more passive persona and prefer to
be subservient in areas of the
relationship although many couples are
content to stay in a moderately female
controlled relationship men who love to
be dominated and women who love to
dominate often up the ante by
transitioning to a more formal level
while sexual kinks are commonly explored
at this level okay so basically he's a
[ __ ] the female isn't necessarily in
charge of the couple's sex life though
her desires may be prioritized
okay let's skip
there's oh there's level three now
define control you know what let's just
go right to level four extreme female
control immersion because i think this
is what probably what most guys
experience today in their marriages once
they go through the betatization process
beta tization by a thousand concessions
good for you good for me
okay level four
couples who enter in an extreme flr are
immersed in female domination and male
sub submissiveness
the female takes complete control on the
relationship deciding how her partner
spends his time and how finances are
handled gee that sounds familiar
where did we hear that before
that was right here
then her controlling ramped up with
increased fighting roller coaster indeed
and she demanded my obedience my time
who i associated with and freedom were
under her control
right
sounds familiar
okay where were we at mail active
servant submit to her partner
at this level nearly if not every aspect
of the male's actions are dictated by
the female he'll likely dress to please
a woman and submit to her every desire
both inside and outside the house these
women would never
never get away with this [ __ ] with me
this like any guy that submits to this
nonsense
you're basically a beta [ __ ] like
you're a plugged in beta for sure
you are you are not living your best
life you're not mental point of origin
and at the end of the day
on a balance of probabilities i would
say she's probably got
something set up like they're in a
polyamorous relationship where she can
go pork wherever she wants so she's
ended up she ends up with like the
subservant beta the plugged in beta
that she controls his every aspect of
his life while she goes out on the
weekend
to pork chad and tyrone
he'll likely dress the please sexually
every kink explorer is based on the
woman's wants needs and desires
probably dude sits in the corner while
she gets you know
you know what i'm saying
uh the couple may delve into hardcore
bdsm at the other extreme the woman may
require complete chastity from her
partner the man has little to no say in
the relationship or the bedroom
so again you're basically a little [ __ ]
previously agreed on punishments can be
a turn-on for both partners as long as
the dynamic is consensuals extreme level
female dominance in a relationship can
be successful
all right let's see what else our friend
what's her name again megan
hi i'm megan that's it
all right what else do they have here
for us that does not sound like fun
a few notes regard like even like even
guys when they lead relationships
they don't do any of this nonsense
rarely i mean if they do they're a
little messed up in the head
you know kind of kind of flipping the
script if you know what i'm saying like
where was that guy's comment so
let's just flip the words around then
him controlling ramped up with increased
fighting a roller coaster indeed and he
demanded my obedience my time who i
associate with
and freedom or under his control
now some might argue but rich
you've said you've got to make sure that
she doesn't go off to vegas with her
girlfriends for a weekend
correct
if she wants to go let her go
right it's just when she comes back make
sure her bags are packed on the front
porch and the lock is changed it's as
simple as that
you're not demanding
she do something it's hey i don't date
women like that i don't live with women
like that i'm not going to be in a
relationship with a woman that behaves
like that girlfriends with boyfriends
don't go to vegas you know to hang out
with their girlfriends for a
bachelorette party doesn't go down
a few notes regarding at the different
levels
she says my number one piece of advice
to couples entering a female-led
relationship or progressing to more
extreme levels is to communicate about
any modifications you was yeah
communicate communicate communicate
communicate that's usually the standard
talking points from the plugged in
narrative right
you just have to negotiate
nope
don't negotiate that's that's by the way
one of the flaws that i find with jordan
peterson's conversations is whenever
he's talking about relationships i've
heard him often make reference to well
then you negotiate you know something in
the relationship and you don't
you can have conversations about stuff
but you're not negotiating like well
i'll do this and then you do that i mean
anytime you try to negotiate anything in
a relationship it often leads to
resentment long term
you just don't respect the other person
while they can certainly natural
progress in open communication blah blah
blah negotiate uh you and your partner
wilson you decide which level of
dominance
so talk about what level you want to be
do you want to be level four extreme
extreme dominance
or you want to go level one
lower female control
megan's got all the notes here for you
okay why women love female-led
relationships okay this will this will
be good
i discussed sorry i discussed flr with
many happily partnered women while
partnered
not married not in a relationship
partner there's that word again right
the progressive word partnered
i discussed female-led relationship with
many happily partnered women while
preparing to write this guide when asked
why these ladies enjoy this type of
relationship they offer the following
answers
i like being in control i like knowing
who handles the finances and who is in
charge of meals and how
so sorry
let me just reread that i like knowing
who handles the finances and she has me
in bracket and who is in charge of meals
and housework him in brackets
my professional life is chaotic
stressful and unpredictable so i like
having full control at home vicky
let's see what paige has to say i felt
com i guarantee vicky is probably one of
these chicks with a piece of paper
framing mahogany with little letters
after her name working at an accounting
firm law firm uh a medical clinic
something right
and then she comes home and brow beats
the [ __ ] out of her husband
get the meals and housework ready bill
i felt comfort so who's next page i felt
comfortable asking my husband if we
could try a female-led relationship
because he liked to be dominated in bed
a great sex life he had zero motivation
every life but he had zero motivation in
everyday life well that turns off women
doesn't it no wonder she's taking a lead
and i was beyond bored with our marriage
yeah i guess our new dominant submissive
roles have spiced up our entire
relationship
he is completely submissive to me now
and we both love it there's no going
back
the clock is ticking down to all of
these relationships all of these stories
what do we got here in the super chats
so what's she saying is she wants a
loser to all the things that she wants
pretty much
uh f psycho f in psychos yeah
oh man uh
nav navia what is that name nivea i
don't know
nev
i've always found my boyfriend
attractive but he lacked a lot of the
qualities i was looking for partner by
taking charge of our relationship i've
helped him become the best version of
himself
he holds a powerful role at work but has
become servant at home he enjoys the
contrast and i find him sexier than ever
i wonder what these people look like
i just
you know i picture
i picture the fat acceptance crowd
covered in tattoos with pronouns like
the alphabet suit pronouns going on
i
i don't know man what do these people
look like i i i gotta ask the question i
got asked a question you know
our relationship is a peaceful one
this is amy we have clear roles and
rules we have no trouble sticking to
them we've been sorry we've both been
much more content since transitioning
yeah i wonder who transitioned did
somebody transition
i love being cherished my boyfriend and
i have been in the flr for six years now
he has made me feel loved and
appreciated every day i'm very much the
dominant and he's passive aside from
showing his adoration for me this
lifestyle just works for us we both feel
more valued than we did in our previous
relationships
you know what i bet there's a way here
let's do this i'm going to minimize this
and
so modern matriarchs
let's see because let's get an idea of
because i said you know what do these
people look like so who's following this
page here
and we have dominatrix mistresses
i hear i can put this up on the screen i
mean this is public we're probably not
going to run into too much trouble with
the youtubes oh look jason mamoa and
lisa bonet are giving their marriage
another chance
probably another female-led relationship
she's like what 55 and he's 40 or
something
anyway uh dominatrix lady becky rose
more dominatrix female lead university
dominatrix dominatrix women women okay
so there's no dudes
that i'm seeing yet
it's mostly dominatrix's i think
mark hamill follows this page isn't that
[ __ ] luke skywalker
what a nerd are you kidding me
[Laughter]
looks like tate was right about star
wars wasn't he
uh we got alice the flirty girl
jessica queen beast um
cardi b
cardi b
is it like the cardi b
diamond pusher yeah cardi b follows this
[ __ ] too are you surprised like isn't
she the one that like
drugged a bunch of guys and stole her
[ __ ] or is that somebody else i
i lose track you guys let me know in the
comments right
yeah i think it was my love for star
wars
mark heimel
uh a bunch of women
well we got mark hom dr daniel grossman
okay another academic dork that's trying
to convince people
well it's a lot of like hot women and
dominatrix typing look type of looking
women right and a couple of celebrities
here and there
i'm not seeing any real men in here like
okay when i say real men i'm talking
about like conventionally masculine oh
hang on a second
here's a dorky couple here with the
co-creator of male chastity day there
you go there's your standard
there's your female-led relationship
couple right there
keyhold it's called
aphrodite sweet mamisa
yeah i think a lot of these women
that i i mean i can't tell hashtag blm
pronouns in the bios i can't tell uh
between the dominatrixes and like the
regular women but
um the regular women should probably get
used to like liking cats
and uh boxed wine subscriptions because
that's pretty much what you end up with
in an unhappy ltr dealing with that
because conventionally the vast majority
of men
um
are definitely preferring more feminine
women i'm talking like conventionally
masking like unplugged alpha males
prefer feminine women that are just
attractive beauties right
and those women like to be in the frame
of strong masculine men that know how to
protect them
can preside can protect has the ability
to make bank lives an interesting life
all that good stuff
oh here's some comments from men oh jeez
let's let's deal with why the met let's
see what megan has to say here
and there's drawbacks after this oh i
can't wait to get to that
um okay
so timothy
timothy
let's get on with timmy
i have a tendency to mess up anything
good in my life so i prefer that my wife
take charge
oh
start from the get-go with disparaging
yourself
i'm a nerd and i can't do anything right
so i want to let my wife take charge i
don't have to concern myself with
decisions that could negatively affect
our relationship
because you'll never make any decisions
dude
in all honesty
i just don't like making important
decisions she does a much better job
all right
there's no power struggle says gavin
gavin this isn't isn't there a
there's a governor in the states gavin
it's in california neustra everybody
hates them don't they from what i
understand my buddy aubrey huff lives
out there
power struggle okay gavin um since we've
defined our expectations and discussed
our roles at home discussed probably
there was some negotiating in there too
as an added bonus it has made parenting
100 easier it's probably because you're
doing all the parenting you nerd
or gavin all right let's see what
dominic's got for us
my passivity has always been views
viewed as a weakness
my female-led relationship has turned
what was perceived as a flaw into a
strength i'm grateful my better half
proposed this arrangement i no longer
wonder if there's something innately
wrong with yeah there is something
innately wrong with you dude
she's probably pegging you man
nor norman we got one from norm norm
i don't view this lifestyle as a
preference i see it as a necessity
i
i work long hours and have to travel a
lot for business my home
home is my escape by being in charge of
virtually every decision my wife makes
my life much happier and easier
let's go back to this dude over here did
he seem like he was happy
then her controlling ramped up with an
increased fighting a roller coaster
indeed and she demanded my obedience my
time who i associated with and freedom
were under her control dude was not
happy he was
pissed all right let's see what megan's
got for us on the drawbacks
i'm a long time fan of female red
relationships for a variety of reasons
but admittedly they aren't for everyone
to thrive each couple must fight find
the relationship style that works best
for them it's important to note that no
relationship is perfect and even good
solid relationships are rocky time
whether to be traditional blah blah blah
that being said i'd like to share some
insight okay these are from the
interviewees
best response when i asked about the
difficulty okay
him and his wife maddie so mark and
maddie are the two of them in this one
absolutely not mark said we're
determined to make this work my wife's
dominance made me insecure after losing
my job so we re-value the power dynamic
and establish new boundaries we're
better than ever so dude loses his job
and is unemployed
and his wife's dominance
kicks in
actually sounds like it kicks into
overdrive
steven says i felt like i was living a
lie because i couldn't open up to my
friends or family members about being a
submissive at home the stigma is
ridiculous
dude it's
stigmas i gotta you know
i gotta laugh at this like progressive
new world order of like
the stigmas
you know who says that
fat isn't sexy it's well it's unhealthy
and most men are not attracted to it so
i want to call it a stigma too
and i wish it didn't affect me or my
relationship but it did
so dude is dude's basically getting
called out by his family for being a
little [ __ ]
dung is fun the best thing about being a
younger guy in shape is you can have
older women and younger women all the
old guys will spend money to get them
and i did not have to spend anything to
get them yeah so you're basically the
alpha seed at that point
women do that these these cougars go for
the younger dudes man just just to get
their itches scratched sometimes
i represented my girlfriend for making
decisions without me and filling in
after making cancel plans she always
repetitive my concerns emilio
what's this one over here shayna
pretty much everything
so here's what women had to say it got
exhausting i'd work all day and come
home to round two home life i was in
control of pretty much everything so i
asked my husband to take on more
response so this is dealing with the
drawbacks she's coming home exhausted
from work and then has to run the
household so i ask my husband to take on
more responsibilities i have the summers
off so she's a teacher
so
how exhausting you know like is your day
i mean you basically work from freaking
what 8 30 to 3 or something like that
and you have your summers off and you've
got all these vacations throughout the
year
anyway i have summers off so i'll resume
my dominant role while i'm on break
right now i'm just too tired see
she's saying she doesn't want to lead
flat out
she doesn't want to leave it's too much
work
i don't want to do it it's too much work
man
kylie it took a long time to establish
boundaries we should have sat down and
written them out from the beginning
it was have it would have saved it was
have saved a lot of come on megan it
would have saved a lot of time energy
and heartache i'd recommend setting
ground rules right away
anyway okay so here's the tips don't
rush it talk it out be patient keep an
open mind consider each other's feelings
be mindful your role seek outside help
megan's willing to help you
anyway
i think that's enough of that nonsense
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you